welcome back to new rock stars one
division's opening episodes have played
things very close to the vest
with exception of a few commercial
breaks selling products designed to
catch the attention of the mcu fans
a toaster from stark industries a
striker watched by hydra
giving us nerds some bear scraps to try
to figure this all out
well this is a special bonus episode of
inside marvel i'm eric boss
here with the man the face who
graciously gave us these marvel easter
eggs
credited only as commercial man at least
so far ithmar enriquez thank you so much
for joining us sithmar
thanks for having me eric this is
exciting this is fun i'm excited that
people are uh excited about this
so if you don't know if mar uh people
who are watching ithmar is a very very
talented hilarious actor and comedian
who
you might have seen him on like herbie
enthusiasm arrested development uh some
of us were the new rockstars team
me tommy zack actually know him from our
la comedy theaters iowa west second city
ithamar was on a sort of house team with
me and tommy that was called wheelhouse
that was uh for a quick minute i feel
like half of hollywood ended up on that
team
we had a lot of rotating cast members
i'm offended i'm offended you call it a
sorta house team i think we were a house
team i don't know we were
a sorta house team well here's the deal
right
when the theater shut down like a few
days before we got a signal that our
team was about to get cut
um and it never ended up happening we
survived the theater in a weird way so
our existence is like still a weirdly
nebulous and undefined but if you happen
to live in the la area or if if mar
happens to be performing in your town
post pandemic if you get a chance to see
this guy perform live you gotta do it i
like make me laugh every time i was in a
scene with you or
just watching you from a show so it's so
cool to see you now
in the marvel cinematic universe thank
you yeah it's been it's been a wild ride
um i was excited to be a part of it but
had no idea i mean i had somewhat of an
idea of the impact the show was going to
make but
so far what it's done is just it's been
overwhelming in the best way possible
yeah um so like
obviously you are sworn to secrecy for
anything coming in future episodes we're
only going to talk about the first two
episodes
uh that have aired so far but like
rewinding a clock to when he first got
the call to do this did
you know what exactly it was for did you
know anything about the one division
premise or concept at that point
uh no so what happened was september of
i got an audition for an untitled marvel
project
and they told me they said we don't know
anything
just know that even the script you're
getting is not the real script they just
want to
see if you can do this type of role so i
went in and i auditioned for it
and it you know it felt fun there was so
much so much mystery around it and then
i heard
nothing at all and then now we cut to
i think august of 2020 so almost a year
later
and my reps call me and say do you
remember that untitled marvel project
you
auditioned for and i was like yeah they
said well you didn't get that
and i was like okay and to this day i
still don't know what that
project was or is i really have no idea
and they're like but there's there's
this other thing
and i was like cool they're like it's
from marvel i'm like great
they're like it's a it's a tv show great
and then they're like and that's all we
know do you want it
this house like well i guess yeah i mean
it's marvel obviously that's very
exciting i have no idea what i'm doing
and
they're like well once you say yes then
they can call you and give you more
information
so i said yes uh the casting person
called me
and filled me in still very little
details
they were just like it's it takes place
like in a tv world
and you'll be doing this and that's all
i can really tell you
uh and i was like yeah so then um
so then we shot and even even in the
middle of shooting
i there was still so much information
kept from us
that we that it was just like you know
they're like
oh and also the script we only got what
we were shooting so we didn't
sure yeah anything surrounding the
commercials or anything
so thankfully matt shachman who directed
uh the episodes such an amazing
kind enthusiastic guy he's juggling all
these plates they're shooting scenes
out of order different episodes all at
once and i mean he just kept his cool
the entire time and
um he made it such a lovely environment
to work in it's so funny to hear you
describe this like we've heard
stories from brie larson when she was
cast in the mcu
where she was just told to show up on
some sound stage with green walls
and they're like react to this piece of
tape and she's like who am i reacting to
and they're like we can't tell you she's
like what movie is this for and they're
like we don't know
so i love getting this inside
perspective
of this uh did were you able to kind of
surmise
from uh from the scene from the context
of just
your lines from the stage direction what
was going on
we didn't really know we just knew that
these were commercials that were within
the show within the show
within the show than the show you know
it's kind of inception uh like
yeah um and that's all we really knew
and
i i hope your uh your fans don't get
upset about this but
my knowledge of marvel up to that point
was okay
it wasn't like i hadn't seen sorry
everybody but i hadn't seen
every avengers movie yet and um you know
i probably knew
as much as any sort of casual viewer so
i kind of got the hints of like
um like the stark and the structure like
okay i think this this
i know this ties into that universe
that's kind of cool but again
that's all we knew we didn't know
anything else as far as like how it was
going to play into the actual story
i thought that maybe was just like a
little tip of the hat to like hey these
are some funny commercials and they just
so happen to be tied to things we've
done before but didn't realize
it was actually specific to the wanda
story
yeah and uh for all we know that might
be
all they are but you know yeah i mean
you've seen our videos now how crazy
we're going about this
looking for clues and uh you know itamar
that's probably for the best
like i'm sure in terms of your
performance you are just a commercial
you know announcer an infomercial guy
who's
just like selling the product he's not
trying to wink
you know to be like this is a historical
reference or anything like that
well it's also fun as a viewer because
um
now i can watch it first of all because
i'm in it but then also like
oh so that's what this is happening so
it's also
i'm watching the episodes as of someone
who's never seen the show either because
i literally haven't and i don't know
what the shows
are about so this has been it's been
really fun for me being like oh that's
cool like this is a cool show
i love that uh to see just like oh
that's how i'm fitting into this
and like and i gotta say like for a lot
of viewers
it's all on ithmar it's like this guy
has all the secrets cause
for the rest of the episode it's you
know there's not a lot of marvel call
outs for the first two
episodes um but like right in that
commercial there's like whoa
whoa whoa we just got a bunch of iron
man stuff there
yeah i want to ask you uh while you're
shooting uh
this like this toaster commercial from
episode one
you know there's this moment where it
goes in close and then the red light
begins to beep and faster and faster and
and you and the other host kind of just
like stall
was that stalling something you had to
do did you have to like awkwardly just
kind of stand there and
react at all or what was it like for you
again the director didn't really
give too much information i think for us
it felt more like hey we got to just get
this coverage
so just sort of like stamp stand there a
bit and just sort of smile at the thing
and they're like
and maybe we may have some voice over
over it we might and again
because marvel is such a trusted brand
as actors we're like yeah
okay whatever you want we'll do that no
questions asked sure
the the leading theory right now is that
that beeping toaster
is like connected to there's a scene in
age of ultron where wanda and her
brother
talk about this stark bomb that landed
in their home and then it just never
detonated but it traumatized them as
they were waiting for it to
explode or not explode obviously you're
not sure where this is going but
as like a fan watching this do you feel
like there's anything to that could we
be barking up the wrong tree
um i don't know if i could answer that
without giving too much away so okay
i'm just gonna i'll plead the fifth on
that one fair enough
fair enough um and another one that i
just have to ask you because
this is something that like on our
discord on my twitter fans are like this
this this this
there's like a clock on the wall behind
you with like a
missing six and a lot of you know
there's this
theory brewing that like the number six
is very important that the hexagons all
over everything
that like the toaster that's the one
that breaks
if you flip that upside down it's 666
and it could all be connected to the
devil
did you see any of this stuff while you
were on set that day did any of this
stand out to you
i mean i saw a clock
i mean i saw a clock so um
uh to answer your question yes there was
a clock behind me
yeah okay that's as much as i could tell
you and again
you know weeks from now we'll might just
look back on this and be like
yeah it was just a clock it was just
i love it it's so much fun though it's
great uh and you know i had to ask you
about that upside down
logo which is probably just a logo of
the toaster but from your vantage point
looking down it
might have looked like a 666 but our
editor john was like my mom has that
toaster and i'm like well your mom's the
devil
i was i i was more distracted by uh the
crew guy
under the shelf who had to physically
push the bread
up from under the toaster i was more
uh interested in that and how they and
how they browned the toast more than
anything else on set oh how did they
brown the toast did he have like a
toy did he have to swap it out yeah they
just kind of like burnt the toast and
put that one in and then
yeah then they would switch the toast
out but yeah it was it was really
no other secret to it than that which i
thought was just brilliant because like
all this time that we think there's all
this movie magic it's like no just bring
in the burnt toast
like all right so there's a there's a
guy in the back just constantly burning
two pieces of toast at all times to have
ready
for this well there you go we just got a
huge easter egg right there you thought
this is just a simple thing with an
actor walking on talking about
toast when really there's this man in
the shadows who's pulling all the
strings
has there ever been an e has there ever
been an easter egg
that was an easter egg like has anyone
ever commented on that like in movies
like it's like
this is an easter egg but it's also an
easter egg yeah uh
you know it's it's rare um because
they're doing fewer and fewer
commentaries now
and like when uh you know sometimes the
more obvious stuff like if it's a cameo
if it's like a crew or cast that they'll
kind of talk about that in the
commentary and be like ah i knew that
person looked familiar
uh or if it's just like you know um
something on a newspaper or something on
a tv screen in the background
but if it's something like an homage or
something that's like foreshadowing
it's sometimes the filmmaker will never
acknowledge it
unless it's something like uh knives out
ryan johnson
build that movie with so many little
clues because the whole thing was like a
mystery you know
um but it's hard i mean we've had on new
rockstars trying to do this education
with our viewers to be like
not everything is an easter egg we're
just pointing out cool details that
sometimes connect this stuff
or just like you can tell the way they
frame this shot that they were hiding
something here
that doesn't necessarily make it an
easter egg it's just something that
shows you that craft was put into this
and you should appreciate that yeah
i want to ask you about the strucker
watch uh you didn't it didn't sound like
you had any lines it was just all voice
over here
uh did they read that voice over to you
on set or was it just like
just stand there smile look in the
mirror i definitely read the voiceover
in the script
as voicer but then once we were shooting
matt just kind of talked us through the
action
yeah uh that one is fun uh but you can
see on the watch it has like a
did you look at that and be like hmm how
does this connect to
uh to the marvel world uh
when i looked at the only thing that um
stood out was just
struck girls like oh yeah i think that i
think that's that's one of the
i'm like i think that's one of the bad
guys
that was and that's all i really knew
did they quickly take it away from you
when you were done shooting they're like
stop looking at it if mark
uh you know they probably used a lot of
sleight of hand like they didn't do it
directly but they're probably
they have it all they're like let's not
get the actors too much information
either so yeah it's like oh look at look
at this shiny thing huh and before you
know my watch is gone
they should have hired they should have
hired an actual like sleight of hand oh
yeah
like a mugger or something to like not
mugger but like a burglar to like yeah
steal stuff without me noticing yeah uh
artful dodger to come in and steal your
hydra watch
meanwhile like toast guy is like here
toast toast toast toast
exactly and uh um so you said you knew
around um uh august of this past year
that it was gonna be for a
like um this marvel tv show since then
you
you know you're you're following me and
tommy on social media have you seen it
seen us talk about watervision just like
shaking her head being like these guys
have no idea what they're getting into
uh it's just for me it's very fun i mean
i've i've never really been part of
something
i shouldn't say that the closest i was
um i did
a couple episodes of a series of
unfortunate events and that also has a
pretty big
like fan base that are very sort of um
die hard lemony snicket fans so that was
that was kind of fun when that came out
it was a little bit of like what does
that mean and um
you know we know he's playing this
character and and then but they had the
actual books to go back to be like well
that character never comes back or that
character is tied to this that
uh but nothing compared to this this is
like i
i'm having such a good time reading all
the speculations
and just just being like oh and just and
and sometimes being like
uh okay that person that person is kind
of close and
and then sometimes we like that person
is not even close at all like
that person is really hoping for
something
that is never going to happen yeah i
mean
we've never had this with i mean there
have been marvel tv shows there's been
like agents of shield agent carter it's
been the runaways but like
true mcu with avengers actors in it
we've never had like
week to week speculation theorizing it's
been like
we get a movie another one's coming out
later this year and there's a
post-credits scene
and a trailer to look at but like this
is insane it's almost scary
how like intense it is well and also
just the actual the style of the show is
so
mysterious that it's it's keeping
everyone on their
on their edge of their seats which is so
fun i love it
now feel free to plead the fifth again
on this one but can we expect to see you
in future episodes or should we just be
happy with what we have so far
um yeah i'll plead the fifth in that one
fair enough
okay fair enough because look i mean to
have a friend who's in the mcu right now
it's like
i don't want to to threaten that or to
jeopardize that at all
so uh just congratulations to you
if mar this is so exciting to see you as
part of this and you're so great in it
as well i'm not just trying to flatter
you like the fact that you're just
playing this part so well
and it just fits in the world of this
show so interestingly and
it's just really cool to see thanks so
much thanks for having me and um
you know when it's all said and done and
uh and we find out that um
it was only those two or whatever else
we could talk again uh
but uh for now thank you so much for uh
for having me this was really fun
yeah uh likewise uh so again be sure to
follow ithmar uh on all of his endeavors
um
and uh tweet at him nice things because
it's always nice to get some
nice attention uh and uh as i was
telling it
before we started rolling new rock stars
were kind of an indie operation we don't
really get invited to red carpets and
stuff like that so it was a true
rare honor to be able to pick your brain
about the show and just
nerd out about it with you uh congrats
excellent work dude uh and it's such a
wonderful show you're such a great part
of it and uh
thank you for joining us for this bonus
episode of inside marvel
um is there anything that uh elsa you'd
like to plug or
uh anything you'd like to shout out uh
no i think i'm good at this point
i i i'm afraid that anything i say will
help
will make people think that i'm dropping
clues even if i just say goodbye
he said goodbye what does that mean he's
a good
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna not say anything for
three months
oh boy uh well um if just a shout out to
our fans i'm wearing our exclusive shirt
from our latest obsession line an
unusual couple it's got hidden easter
eggs revealed via augmented reality it's
a crazy shirt you can get it at our
merch store newrockstarsmerch.com
uh if you do get this you can write in a
custom shout out that we'll feature on
screen on our friday episodes of inside
marvel
follow ithamar on twitter at ifmar
enriquez follow me at eavos
uh follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars and youtube subscribe to
inside marvel wherever we get your
podcasts
see you next time if mart thanks again
and uh we'll see you in the future
[Music]
you